So for a long time, I've advocated
this approach of Mobile First.
And the reason why I've pushed for that
is 341, mobile's a huge opportunity.
If you look at the scope of it,
it's much,
much bigger than what we've had
before with personal computers.
Two, mobile has new capabilities.
For example, with a desktop or
laptop, we knew with 99% certainty
you were in the U.S. Yay.
WIth mobile we can get you
down to like 50 meters,
which is a huge, huge difference.
And there's a lot of other capabilities
like multi-touch and all the sensors and
devices that we didn't have before.
But the third one, which I thought was
actually the most impactful was if you
go from a typical 1024 by 768
screen down to a 320 by 480,
kind of early smartphone screen,
you've lost 80% of your screen space.
Which means you need to think really,
really hard about what
can fit on that screen, because you
can't fit everything from before.
So you have to do this really
hard thing called prioritization.
And in order to prioritize, you have
to understand what you're doing for
people, why and how.
And when you think about all
these different devices,
mobile is a great forcing function for
getting you down to the core essence,
to what really matters?
How fast and easy can we make this?
Maybe the watch is another forcing
function because you should be able to,
I saw people ordering pizzas
with their voice on their watch.
But the less capabilities you have,
the more creative you have to get
with how people can get stuff done.
So it's a great way to essentially
force yourself to, well,
we have this 40 screen check out form or
40 input field check out form,
can we get it down to five,
what would that take?
Would that even work?
And when you do it on the desktop,
you don't have that concern.
It's like oh yeah,
there's plenty of room.
I'll just add field number 45 on page 3.
People can type.
So on a multi-device we're all right.
I think it helps to have that filter
first, to get down to the core
essence and then you can bring
that core essence everywhere.
because why should someone with a 20
inch monitor suffer through 40 form
fields, where someone with a 4 inch
monitor gets away with only five, right?
They should equally get
the same treatment.